olá a todos pessoal do que fala e rodar
que sejam muito bem vindos de mais um
vídeo e os estragos e que foi finais 7
fredes 2 e hoje nós vamos jogar aqui no
83 e muitos de vocês já disseram que
esta noite é muito mas muito mais
complicada em relação à segunda e é isso
que o governo chinês o alvo que dar o
meu entender e vamos lá então jogar a
terceira noite
é eu sei que nesta noite chic o fred eo
foco se já devem estar furiosos comigo
eu vou tentar ficar mais atento agora as
luzes ao palhaço e aqui à frente também
é preciso meu comentário ficar assim um
crime mais demorados e um calor assim
durante mais tempo pessoal é normal é
porque estou concentrado pra tentar
passar a noite e quero perceber que o
tempo aqui do palhaço está mais rápido
eu acho ok vou dar muito capital não sei
que vocês não gostam mas aquilo
atrapalha minha se eu quero passar este
obstáculo pistas mesmo passei mais
hardcore nyon
já o meia noite wilson brandão aqui
o cade não tinha percebido em 2007 este
é o zé coelho do fluminense fred sun ele
não tenha aparecido ainda calma embora
maneira lá vai embora
foi a cena que aparece está tranquilo
tranquilo é meia noite eu já tenho um
parceiro meu é meu deus à tona parceiro
vou ficar aqui muito tempo só vou ficar
aqui muito tempo subir sair tarde e por
isso mesmo porque fiquei muito tempo a
passar esta porcaria mel
o mercado agora a raposa estão dois à
minha frente eu não posso fazer nada
porque aí será mais pela via rápida
junto da lei também o que os arquivos já
foi maior ainda atrapalha muito o jogo
atrapalha muito meu atrapalha muito o
dólar cair alguém está na ventilação
virtual virtual virtual heroes of fado
dom josé pinto e também calma
calma quando avançar daqui pra frente só
vamos ter a máscara é isso que tem feito
foi 5 passei a noite dois por isso é
assim que vou tentar passar agora 83
calma aqui palhaço ok você pinto meta
mas cansou um pouco só pelo sim pelo não
a mais que a raposa josé pinto nem dali
não ensina aqui pela anac estava uma
data mágica só toma sair muito bem e
agora estou aqui vai fazer você pensar
por ser que venha o palhaço é palhaço
calma eu não estou tendo a pagar senão
tentar pegar a banda não podem entrar
para dentro palhaçada podendo subir foi
o palhaço eu sabia pessoal a ser
espalhado da caminho eu não pode ser meu
eu tenho que ficar mais atento o palhaço
eu tento dizer pinto destruíam do
palhaço e não deixou que a caixa
o caps lock ok vamos lá vamos lá tudo
bem tá tudo muito muito bem
eu tenho aqui à frente já apareceu à
meia noite meu como é que é possível
josé raposo xapuri natal palhaço
palhaçaria lá não acaba muito mais
rápido agora pessoal carlos do tranquilo
porque fui embora mas eu fui embora
agora é tempo pra eu vir aqui o palhaço
lá lá eu tenho controlar muito bem o
tempo do palhaço pessoal este gajo é que
no lixo é sempre que as coisas só cai
eu não posso deixar que um é mais caro
ainda que o boni através de como estava
a cápsula não posso deixar que este caso
é visto por isso não vai me faltar em
cima mas chegou a estar aqui
ok ok anac josé campos em jogo do grupo
c ou seja que não há ninguém aqui está
tudo tranquilo é amigos e não quero
fazer mal a muita máscara
ok pois já se foi embora mas falar as
palavras palavras palavras palavras
palavras palavras ok
está tudo tranqüilo está tudo tranquilo
tranquilo tranquilo uma da manhã pelo
mendes já conseguimos uma da manhã eu
não tenho certeza está pouco chegamos à
uma da manhã
mas é esta manhã duas da manhã
afinal são duas que eu agüentava em
calma calma lá anda aqui é daqui do
balão né não
música tato tranquilo vai aparecer
alguém aqui eu não vi ninguém mas esta
música indica sempre vai aparecer alguém
não não é uma caixa de música
josé rabumba janela palhaço calma calma
calma lá aguenta raposa jogou entanto
raposas aguenta e numa sutil
o cantor solo ou seja não está muito
difícil está muito difícil mesmo jato
suor por todos os lados mel não só por
todos os lados está tranqüilo palhaço é
palhaço é palhaço é palhaço lá na nela
isso ok ok solo segredo é que eu acho
que mesmo controlar que o palhaço porque
é o time de luxa sempre lá na vila
liberdade gastou sua companhia por um
dique meu
afinal matou o jogo através meu gol
agora é o bicho eo para adaptar meu gol
31 por exemplo era eu não consigo ver o
que está aqui em cima gift é isso tem
que ter essas coisas todas
só nos falta um ok eu não consigo
perceber o que é que isto é mas é uma
espécie de bicho tá aqui meu não sair e
agora tentar outra vez por ponte está
quietinha tá aqui uns e pinto já não se
vê nada eu já não possuem nada ele era o
gol do fred não é ok vamos lá através
pessoal do meu cabelo até já tática
irmão que tanto medo vai mostrar outra
vez vamos passar esta terça feira à
noite ainda hoje meu eu prometo a lutar
aqui alguém não está obviamente porque
ainda meia noite não é tem que praticar
em o palhaço é muito rápida acabar o
tempo é muito mais rápido agora lá lá só
eu vou ter que ser muito mais rápido por
isso eu calar e não tiver a comentar
nada de jeito é porque estou focado e
concentrado no gameplay por isso eh eh
se ficar assim que nunca lado não
estranhe é porque está mesmo concentrado
e bora lá passar esta noite pessoal a
sério vou ter que passar esta noite o
zool hoje tem que ser hoje meu ok lá
tranquila e esgoto estão tranquilas
palhaço está bom também
desta vez não foi o palhaço quem tramou
foi mesmo bolinha antigo bonito failed
at freddy's um não tinha de tirar a
máscara mais por instinto tiro e foi por
causa disso que eu morri mas bora lá ok
uma da manhã ou o tempo estava mais
rápida até o gol ou meta mas claro que o
foco é a carioca é só o foco é só os
raposas corda no palhaço corda no
palhaço lá isso ninguém a ventilação nas
souto irá incluir vai só devem ser com
as duas
só que aí o outro inteira mas calma lá
onde está agora um de turismo já ia
morrer à toa isso boa nas na espuma da
manhã e só devem se com as duas eu saí
lá muda hora muda hora muda hora
tranqüilo aqui tranquilo aqui também
está tudo tranqüilo agora só bom eu já
só tem dois títulos estaduais meu está
acabado muito rápido
através do toque pessoal eu vou ter que
gastar menos energia vai acontecer
alguma coisa que o fox e também o caso
do palhaço pega pega pra mim trabalhar
com calma calma está tudo tranquilo está
tudo ok ok o foxit por seu fox e
desapareceu na não há agora tem tempo
porque o palhaço um pano macio será
franca
com ela eu já sei do balão também
calma calma calma isso o costuma ser bem
são duas da manhã
são duas da manhã à capital estão a
aguentar bem alguém está na ventilação ó
kaytto que os do genesis meu
calma calma dark ataques rápidos depois
da ventilação ter mais cuidado agora o
outro parceiro da ventilação
nós vamos estar nem eu vou mostrar agora
né
são duas da manhã ouviu um barulho
estranho
acredita que fosse calma pelas calma
pelas que não estrague o jogo aliás
falar senão ac milan anda isso discutir
a questão é quem vai dar o que achei bem
ok ok a gente vai andar que está em você
por seu clã
eu não sei como vai ficar agora não aqui
está tudo tranquilo
só tenho um flash lite agora pessoal eu
não sei se está a minha lanterna da
frente ou c estas lusa que as portas não
faz ideia mas são três da manhã estão a
aguentar muito tempo só faltam três
olhos
ok
tranquilo tranquilo calma calma o
assunto porque no momento eu não vou
tirar a máscara não vou tirar a máscara
não vou tirar a máscara eu não vou tirar
a calma eu vou deixar que vai embora sua
calma calma calma calma ainda não foi
atrapalhado pelas palhaçadas estava de
frente estava o frei chico também anda
calma calma cama boa boa jogada ainda
que está a jogar muito bem agora são
quatro minutos depois outra vez outra
vez bonin eu vou deixar que ele
desapareça eu espero que no mato como há
pouco calma desaparece vai com o tempo
vai com calma isso agora é palhaço é
palhaço é palhaço é palhaço é palhaço é
palhaço é palhaço ela toque pessoal nem
sei como é que eu consegui sobreviver a
isso eu eu passei uns três ao mesmo
tempo meu
calma calma eu estou muito nervoso e
histérico solo treme por todos os lados
eu to muito eu quero passar esta noite
que fala sério
eu quero passar o resto da noite
o cantor que os 2 mil
só que os dois alguém vende lução alguém
ir pela ventilação
ok tem que ter muita atenção agora só
quer pagar as parcelas pagas palhaço sua
vida calma daqui ok você aparecer alguém
vinculação não ok eu quero atrapalhar as
palavras sua vida
chove câmara anda anda anda muito bem
dark rock às cinco da manhã pessoas
inclusive manhã ele poderia acabar calma
calma calma daqui calma da acral pagar
só o palhaço é palhaço
ok tudo tranquilo
pintou força daqui vai embora com tempo
com calma porque ainda estou aqui eu sou
aqui ainda acham que ainda estou um
tanto que os raposas calma palhaço é
palhaço é palhaço é palhaço é palhaço é
palhaço é palhaço elétrico boas deixa eu
ir embora vá lá lançou às 15 horas da
manhã e às 5 horas da manhã lá lá eu fui
embora por si moura baterista quais
acabaram a andar
meu coração estava tentando no curso um
tapa de tanto escutar rock mãe o passar
do jogo
está a acontecer alguma coisa kimmel
só fui visitar a minha mãe pela terceira
noite está a passar aqui porque é muito
parado
tati cuba e fred
não gosto não gosto de isto não deveria
ter essas coisas meu ipod também né 1
quarta noite pessoal vai ser o meu
querido no clube o athex caiu com medo
eu vou tentar colocar ainda hoje é
quarta 18 calorias é maluco phone
windows tentar colocar o quarto é muito
comuns com vídeo no canal por isso há
porém mesmo fortemente este vídeo e e só
quando vou falar em favorito fiquem bem
até a próxima e deixe me tirar isso de
opinião surge bons
ae
[Música]